[Music]
on this friday night state of emergency
ontario introduces new measures to end
the protests will changing tactics be
enough nobody's seen a demonstration
like this before plus the steps being
taken to clear the border blockades
you're hurting your neighbors
it's time to go home
rising tensions the stark warning leave
ukraine as the threat of the russian
invasion escalates
and jamaican comeback after a long and
bumpy ride at the country's beloved
bobsled team is back at the olympics
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight eric
sorenson good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with
breaking news an injunction has been
granted to remove the protesters from
the ambassador bridge this comes after
ontario's premier said he intends to
enact an order that states that the
occupations taking place in ottawa and
windsor are illegal a sentiment the
prime minister has echoed
the illegal blockades
are hurting canadians
whether they're in ottawa windsor coots
or emerson
they're endangering jobs
they're threats to our economy and to
public safety
so some form of intervention in windsor
now appears to be imminent but as sean
o'shea explains it's unclear how any
attempt to break up the protest will be
received sean
eric in the last 24 hours police here
have received backup from the ontario
provincial police and the rcmp it's
expected if people occupying this area
don't leave of their own accord they'll
be forced to
they've been here all week protesters
occupying the canadian end of the
ambassador bridge that links windsor
ontario with detroit michigan the
actions of a hundred or so protesters
and their trucks have created an
international crisis and now their time
is running short
we've tried and tried and tried with
ontario declaring a state of emergency
police now have more powers the trade
problems that we would see if we didn't
clear
the ambassador bridge
would be unprecedented businesses on
both sides of the border have already
cut production in factories this is the
right to protest if we can't protest a
bad government will do whatever they
want against the people that's what
they're doing now police reinforced
tighter restrictions on access to the
site yet protesters were freely allowed
to bring gasoline and other fuel back to
their vehicles where they've been living
and sleeping what's wrong with fueling
up the vehicle
police told us they can't stop the
resupply effort so will those occupying
the bridge follow a court order to leave
will they follow an injunction that is
illegal
probably not walking on the street i
asked one protester whether an
injunction would be followed imagine
just like in any scenario there might be
someone who says i don't like that
right or someone who shakes their fist
the sky
it doesn't mean
violence and a question also likely
being asked by police do the police have
anything to worry about from the
perspective of push back fight back guns
resistance
the only thing the police have to worry
about is god's judgment
on their actions late this afternoon the
city of windsor and the automakers got
their wish they got that court
injunction requiring the protesters to
leave tonight whether they go that's
still up in the air eric
sean o'shea in windsor ontario thanks
sean despite the declaration of a state
of emergency the protests in ottawa
appear to be growing again as abigail
beeman tells us the protesters do not
appear to be phased by the threat of
consequences
it's friday so more protesters spill
downtown ottawa ahead of the third
weekend in a row
a dj'd street dance party porta potties
in front of the prime minister's office
and camped out protesters all under the
ontario premier's new state of emergency
there will be consequences for these
actions and they will
be severe doug ford promising to protect
against blocking infrastructure
including border crossings airports
bridges and roads maximum penalty of one
hundred thousand dollars
and up to a year imprisonment
we will also provide additional
authority
to consider taking away the personal and
commercial licenses of anyone who
doesn't comply and you're not afraid of
a fine or an arrest or anything nope
i've got my husband on speed dial in
case he needs pay bail none of the
protesters we spoke to are phased by a
state of emergency i'm here for the long
haul we're not going back doing any of
that until all mandates are removed
makes me want to stay more i'm tired of
being told what to do just like
everybody else here freedom means
freedom if you don't understand it
dictionaries are available online for
free many frustrated by protests have
long been calling for tougher action on
day 15 the state of emergency seems the
biggest move so far it's my hope with
the additional powers announced today
and the new resources we are continuing
to work on getting
from our policing partners that we can
bring a safer and swifter lawful end to
the illegal demonstration while the city
of ottawa announced it will be seeking a
court injunction everything is on the
table the prime minister says the quote
unlawful activity will end i can't say
too much more now as to exactly when or
how this ends because unfortunately we
are concerned about violence as for
whether ottawa needs to call in the
military to help the prime minister says
they're not seriously considering that
right now and it's something he'd like
to avoid at all costs but also that they
have to be quote ready for any
eventuality eric
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you
abigail
the toronto police department is gearing
up to move protest vehicles out of the
city if illegal demonstrations
materialize this weekend the police
chief says peaceful protests are allowed
but not encampments or road blockades
we have assets in place to make sure if
people are
if vehicles are engaged and they're
they're not moving we're going to move
them out of the way
they say the priority is to keep
emergency routes clear and protect key
infrastructure several roads are closed
and police are asking people to avoid
the area
in the west industry groups are warning
a nearly two week long blockade at the
border crossing south of kutz alberta
could soon have catastrophic impact on
that province's economy rcmp officers
are ticketing protesters but as heather
urex west explains farmers and
manufacturers say a resolution is needed
now
winter weather may have returned to
southern alberta but protesters remain
committed to their cause for two weeks
the blockade at the coots border
crossing has been mostly peaceful but
its impact on industry has been anything
but we estimate that the impact on that
is about 600 million dollars over the
last two weeks very few of the
protesters here in southern alberta are
commercial truckers in fact many of the
people we have spoken with work in
agriculture or oil and gas industries
that now say they are hurting because of
this blockade if manufacturers can't
provide the materials needed in oil and
gas then ultimately it's going to impact
our biggest sector which is the energy
industry it's days not weeks before we
start to see shutdowns alberta's cattle
industry is hurting too eighty percent
of beef produced here is exported it's
why the president of the canadian
cattlemen's association is calling for
the protest to end i believe it's gone
too far now it started to disrupt trade
it started to disrupt commerce there's
people that lost their jobs because they
would not take an experimental vaccine
so i just think it's time to share the
pain at the end of the day we're talking
profits
but i think profits
are not above freedom and so the protest
continues as the blockade at alberta's
busiest border crossing enters week
three heather urex west global news near
milk river alberta
the protests have largely been about
covid restrictions well it looks like
some changes are coming the federal
health minister said today the worst of
the omicron wave is behind us and ottawa
could tweak travel restrictions by next
week
our government is actively reviewing the
measures in place at our borders and we
should be able to communicate changes on
this
next
week the government currently advises
against all non-essential trips outside
this country those who do travel are
subject to covet 19 measures when they
return including testing chief public
health officer dr teresa tam says
because omicron is so infectious it is
too hard to stop every case at the
border
overseas protesters in france are headed
for paris inspired by the demonstrations
in this country thousands of police
officers and armored vehicles are
positioned around the capitol waiting
for the convoy gatherings are banned in
paris but as crystal gomezing reports
many protesters there are also willing
to risk the consequences
[Music]
the french prime minister warned anyone
blocking the streets of paris would be
arrested
keeping to that word police and armored
vehicles moved into place friday as the
so-called european freedom convoy was
expected to arrive
those in the french convoy and their
supporters at locations outside of paris
appear unfazed jovial even
[Music]
when asked about the convoy and support
for it there are some common talking
points canadians they uh kind of
federate all the people so that's why
they're in australia in new zealand and
now in europe and france the people look
at it and uh i guess it really pushed
them to to go on the street
the words canadians freedom and fairer
world are often cited it's unclear if
there's any coordination between all of
the convoys there is cross-promotion of
different country events on the european
social media page
the demonstrators call for freedom but
in france many covet 19 restrictions
have been removed outdoor masking was
dropped earlier this month and by the
end of february there won't be any
requirements indoors at bars or
restaurants although the vaccine
passport will still be needed
i see that we've had significant loss of
freedom in the past two years and it's
important that people mobilize
those who have mobilized have so far
been prevented from entering city limits
crystal gomansing global news london
a sharp warning from the white house
tonight that a russian invasion of
ukraine could happen at any moment
canada joined several other nations
today urging its citizens to leave
ukraine now top u.s security officials
have laid out what a russian attack
could look like starting with an aerial
bombing campaign
jackson proskow joins us now from
washington jackson what more do we know
tonight
hi eric the white house insists that it
does not believe vladimir putin has made
a final decision on an invasion but the
tone today was unmistakable president
biden's national security adviser told
reporters that russia is in position to
mount a major military campaign any day
now and it could happen while the
olympics are still ongoing in addition
to urging americans to leave within the
next 24 to 48 hours they warned no u.s
military personnel will step onto
ukrainian soil to assist with evacuating
citizens in the event of an invasion the
u.s embassy continues its drawdown of
staff and there is growing concern that
a bloody assault beginning with missiles
and airstrikes and bombings could be the
first salvo in any russian attack it
could take a range of different forms
but i want to be equally clear that one
of those forms
is a rapid assault on the city of kyiv
that is a possible
line of attack course of action that the
russian forces could choose to take now
tonight we're learning that the u.s is
ordering an additional 3 000 troops to
poland that's on top of the nearly 2 000
dispatch there last week they are not
meant to fight russia in ukraine but
rather to deter any advance on nato
members today there was an 80 minute
long phone call between the u.s canada
and european allies the white house
insists they're all united and ready to
levy sanctions and other countermeasures
against vladimir putin and his inner
circle if needed but eric officially
they aren't giving up on diplomacy yet
and the white house expects that
president biden will speak with putin by
phone this weekend
thanks jackson jackson proskow in
washington tonight
breaking rank from the canadian armed
forces
coming up the military officer being
investigated for speaking out against
pandemic mandates
plus the olympics welcome back a fan
favorite
[Music]
welcome back a major in the canadian
armed forces is under investigation
tonight for appearing in a video
speaking about covet 19 mandates he is
the latest military member to speak out
and as ross lord reports the canadian
forces says appropriate action will be
taken
it's almost unheard of for a serving
member of the canadian armed forces to
speak out against government policy
especially like this canadians have been
lulled into believing that the same
government who suppresses your freedoms
in the name of safety will one day just
reward you back with your freedoms army
major stephen schladowski adopting a
popular buzzword of those protesting
covet 19 rules and vaccines
that folks is the very definition of
tyranny
schledowsky says he's served in the
forces for almost 21 years
including in canada's mission to
afghanistan he also says he's
unvaccinated four months after dnd
ordered members to be fully vast along
with other public servants schledowsky
refused a global news request for an
interview
the department of national defense says
it's investigating dnd says these are
difficult and stressful times for our
country and the canadian armed forces is
not immune to these stressors the
department says discipline and being
accountable to duly elected officials
are crucial for military members noting
those who disregard these principles
undermine the very foundation of our
institution and that anyone who brings
discredit to the forces will be held
accountable can receive in his video
schledowsky urges other military and
police members to oppose covet-related
policies
it comes as canadian intelligence
reports indicate far-right extremists
are looking for ways to recruit soldiers
and cops they know when to start
conveying these types of messages within
within the military ranks
to other potentially susceptible
individuals so um
it's problematic and it's an incredibly
difficult challenge
another layer of complexity at a time of
widespread unrest ross lord global news
ottawa
securing the capital
ahead was ottawa ever ready for a
disruptive occupation
you're watching global national
[Music]
the protests over the last two weeks
have tried tactics never seen before in
canada
security was prepared to keep trucks
away on parliament hill but on the
streets of the city and at border
crossings ordinary life was brought to a
standstill the question is will
authorities be better prepared next time
because experts believe there will be a
next time
the first miscalculation was thinking
protesters would stay one weekend and
leave instead they turned their trucks
into urban barricades impossible to get
by or ignore
there was nothing that indicated that it
would be
this level of interference with the
normal way of life doug kirkland managed
security on parliament hill for years
nobody's seen a demonstration like this
before at the center of government
always a potential target security is
constantly evolving in 1989 a hijacked
bus was driven onto the hill a few years
later a man ran his jeep up the steps of
center block
911 prompted still tighter security
eventually parliament hill was made
off-limits to all but official vehicles
that at least may have kept tractor
trailers from steamrolling onto the hill
two weeks ago
but while parliament hill itself was
spared protesters sealed off the main
thoroughfare wellington street with
trucks and more trucks came and more
streets were blocked off protesters
choking off ordinary life in the city
for thousands of residents and not just
for one day the protests have definitely
created some new tactics that haven't
been seen in canada before and i think
that it's a tactic that we may see grow
it didn't take long for other small
groups to realize how easy it can be to
gum up canada's economic lifelines
but police learned too in toronto
traffic was steered away from queen's
park the optics of sticking a truck in
the face of government deflected in
ottawa one response could be as simple
as putting portable barricades in place
sooner and further out to discourage big
rigs from being used as big props but
the issue in the capital is also
jurisdiction the bureaucracies we
certainly have them stacked up on top of
each other federal municipal two
provincial governments different police
forces it seems to take so long for
authorities to get together to respond
there's got to be a streamlined table
there has to be some kind of
interrelationship that can be put
together very quickly out of this may
come new laws that can be applied
quickly with heavier penalties
restrictions which could boomerang on
so-called freedom protests the irony of
the protests is they're actually
potentially going to limit freedoms in
the long run
still the protests unleashed new methods
and discovered new streams of funding on
social media by any measure one small
group showed just what is possible in
canada it may set a tone for what's to
come
but
this was the first
still ahead back on track the jamaican
bobsled team is making a comeback
decades after defying olympic odds
there's a cloud of controversy in
beijing tonight over one of the biggest
stars in one of the biggest events she
is camila valleva the 15-year-old figure
skating sensation from russia she tested
positive for a banned substance before
the olympics but it was only revealed
after she led russia to a gold medal in
the team event now the court of
arbitration will decide her fate whether
she can compete in the upcoming singles
final and whether canada will move up
from fourth place to a bronze medal in
that team event
well one of the feel-good stories at the
first winter games in canada 34 years
ago was the debut of the four-man
bobsled team from jamaica of all places
well they're coming back to the 2022
olympics and as jamie dahl reports the
sprinters who first took to the ice are
watching closely
they were the underdogs from a tropical
island nation blazing an icy trail for
future winter athletes to come have
never seen snow let alone a bobsled
track the world instantly fell in love
with the jamaican bobsled team when they
debuted at the 1988 olympics in calgary
jamaica's athletes have been stealing
the spotlight in calgary my mother
doesn't exactly know what it is but
she's
go ahead enjoy yourself have a nice time
this thing was way bigger than just four
guys from jamaica
trying to bobsled it was saying to
people
all over the world
uh who had dreams that they
thought may be scary or too big or some
seemed ridiculous and impossible and
other people telling them i think it
gave them permission to go pursue those
dreams themselves and now after a
24-year absence jamaica's four-man
bobsleigh team is headed back to the
track in beijing it's about time
calgary's lost brown has competed at the
olympics for both canada and jamaica i
think jamaican have some really good
athletes
and
putting it together and getting them
back on track like that's that's nice to
see if the the jamaican boys finish in
the top ten
that's an accomplishment you bring that
jamaican
flair
to the games you know and that's that
makes it a pretty cool event i just
encourage them to
enjoy the moment man because it's it's
one of those very rare experiences that
that so few of us get to enjoy in life
that famous movie made about the 88 team
helped preserve the significance of the
jamaican bobsled team's legacy
regardless of how they do in china you
can bet the world will be watching every
heart-stopping turn
jamie dawg local news calgary
it's not always about winning the gold
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm eric sorenson tonight's
york canada is a seal lounging in
newfoundland and labrador's green bay
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching
[Music]